nova djokovic fue liberado el ues
australiano anthony que le ordenó este
lunes la liberación del tenista número
uno del mundo del hotel en melbourne que
funciona como un centro de detención
para inmigrantes y refugiados en el que
se concentraba desde el pasado jueves
por haber ingresado al país con una
extensión médica que el gobierno federal
no consideró válida para justificar su
estado de no vacunado el argumento
principal de la defensa de djokovic fue
que el deportista ha superado el cob y
19 en dos ocasiones la última de ellas
en diciembre djokovic se marchó a
entrenar después de su liberación así lo
compartió en su cuenta de instagram y
además con una declaración de
intenciones estoy satisfecho y
agradecido con que el juez haya
revertido la cancelación de mi visa a
pesar de todo lo que ha pasado en la
última semana y quiero quedarme e
intentar competir en el abierto de
australia sigo concentrado en eso
mientras tanto desde belgrado compareció
la familia de djokovic para celebrar
esta victoria del número uno del tenis
mundial
hemos venido a celebrar la victoria de
nuestro hijo de nuestro novak un joven
que ha aprendido en su familia a no
tolerar la mentira a no tolerar el
fraude siempre ha luchado por la
justicia no es culpable de nada no hizo
nada que vaya en contra de las leyes y
sin embargo sufrió semejante tortura a
pesar de la decisión judicial en favor
del deportista el ministro de
inmigración australiano alex que aún
contempla la posibilidad de deportarlo
pero el tiempo corre en contra de
djokovic este martes el serbio debe
confirmar su participación en el primer
gran slam del año que comienza el
próximo lunes 17 de enero en el defiende
su corona y buscaría su vigésimo primer
gran torneo en su carrera algo que sería
un récord en la rama masculina